hi everyone welcome to another episode
of science and technology q a for kids
and others
i'm going to try and answer questions
that
you guys give me
about um well anything you want in
science and technology i'll do my best
um i see here a question that came in on
our submission form from sam
how was it possible for civilizations
across the world to both develop
pyramids independently egypt the mayans
aztecs etc is there scientific
significance to this
interesting question
um
you know
in
both technology and biology there is
occasionally convergent evolution
like for example the eye
taking light
turning it into
uh nerve impulses electrical signals and
nerves
the eye has been invented multiple times
in in biological history
and uh
each time it's been invented like like
for example we have eyes
that have a particular arrangement of
cells on the retina compare on the on
the on the back of the eye
um and uh
we actually our eyes got it wrong we
have some cross connections in front of
our retinas so that all the light all
the photons of light have to go through
the cross connections before they get to
the light sensitive cells on the back of
our retina things like i think king
crabs
evolved eyes independently and got that
right
so
there are cases in both biology and
technology where things get invented
sort of independently um and uh end up
being sort of functionally the same and
i suspect that's what happened with
pyramids because i suspect that
it was kind of like well you can arrange
things in a particular way and this is a
way so the stones don't fall down and it
looks cool
and so it got independently invented
there's some they're definitely some
mysteries in terms of independent
invention like one of the ones i've been
curious about
is kind of labyrinth shapes kind of
maze-like shapes
there's a particular maze shape
that uh
you see on coins from crete for example
and um
from uh i don't know fourth fifth
century bc things like that
and it's a particular pattern but that
same pattern shows up
in
uh in south america
it shows up um in other places in europe
and
i found that quite mysterious because
it's a pattern where it doesn't really
seem to be that distinguished from other
patterns seems like you could have
invented a bunch of different maze
patterns but that particular maze
pattern shows up in in those different
places and it kind of eventually tells
one well there was presumably some kind
of communication because it's sort of a
random thing that showed up it's not
like it's not like a pyramid where you
start piling rocks up in a sort of a
a it feels almost inevitable that you'll
end up inventing the idea of a pyramid
this seems a bit more specific you know
that particular maze pattern um has a
funny history it's it's um has certain
some kind of mythical uh character it's
it's sometimes um
uh
uh daedalus
is said to have been um the architect of
the labyrinth of the minotaur the
minotaur was some kind of bull
composite uh monster creature that lived
in the in the sort of uh it lived in the
basement of the palace and and on crete
um at least is said to have done so and
apparently that uh i think the myth goes
that dealer's famous um
uh chat from antiquity uh mythical chat
from antiquity um designed that
labyrinth and then i think there's also
a statement that it was the the um the
logo of the city of troy or maybe it was
the the design of the of the city walls
of the city of troy but anyway a
particular pattern that just shows up in
a bunch of different places
you know there are other things where
you could say
how convergent was the evolution
how divergent
another one is like numbers
you know the idea of numbers got
invented multiple times
uh the idea of writing got invented at
least three times
but each time writing got invented which
time numbers got invented they were
configured a bit differently like for
example the kind of the tradition
uh from
oh ancient babylon cuneiform with
phoenicians leading to our alphabet and
so on that was sort of a very alphabetic
system
whereas
uh for example the you know the chinese
system is is idiographic
uh characters represent whole words
effectively um different invention
different construction for language
there are some features of language that
are sort of curiously convergent like
for example
if you look at the languages of the
earth there are maybe
7 000 languages that are still in use
today
unfortunately languages uh can go
extinct
when you know language is only really
fun to use if if multiple people talk it
um if you're the last speaker of some
particular language
it's tough to um
to justify continuing to use it is not a
good form of communication because there
aren't other people you can communicate
with in that language and so there's a
certain rate unfortunately in modern
times of the languages going extinct but
i think there are about seven thousand
still left and one can ask
kind of what commonalities are there
what convergence of evolution what
divergence of evolution are there in
those languages and sometimes you can
see the definite families of languages i
mean english for example is part of the
indo-european family of languages but
there are many other families of
languages
occasionally there are languages which
are isolites
languages like i believe basque language
in in northern spain is an example of an
isolate that
is a language where there's just nothing
else quite like it anywhere
there are other languages like like for
example finnish hungarian family of
languages that are different from the
other european languages um but are at
least in a in a group by themselves but
you know so you can kind of trace
the um the the
sort of evolution of languages but but
there are certain things which seem to
sort of always be there like nouns and
verbs and adjectives and so on those are
always there it seems in every human
language and those are places where in a
sense the the presence of those things
probably has something to do with the
way that that uh sort of our brains are
set up and the way that we
we tend to think about things
you know it's it's a um i'm always very
curious about the structure of languages
and
uh the extent to which one needs a
particular form and in designing
computational language um i've certainly
leveraged the fact that people are so
familiar with human languages which have
certain characteristics you know verbs
tend to be very much like functions and
programs and so on nouns are like
entities and literals and things like
this
um and it's useful to kind of leverage
that that understanding
but in terms of um
uh
i'm curious you know if one looks at
sort of the evolution of technology
in the world
um
you know ideas like wheels or fire
uh you know were these invented multiple
times or was did it have did they have
one inventor and did these things then
spread i think different kinds of things
will have had different
uh levels of of one inventor-ness
uh
the thing that i always find interesting
is there are there are more things than
you might think that just had one
inventor where it wasn't obvious it was
going to happen ever and
somebody somewhere invented it
um i think that um
i mean it's probably worth remembering
that in the in in antiquity there were
many fewer people around in the world
than there are today and so many fewer
sort of places for invention although
sometimes invention is easier when there
are fewer people around because when
there are lots of people around there's
a there's a certain collective belief
that oh no you can't invent that that's
not um you know we all know it works
this way whereas if there are fewer
people there's there's less kind of
a herd mentality of what you have to do
but uh it is um
um
certainly
uh it's it's often there are things
where
uh so they finally got invented
and you say why was this never invented
before
um
and uh
it's surprising that it wasn't i mean
they're things that i've been lucky
enough to discover in my life in science
and so on where you look at them uh
particularly things that involve you
know simple rules and just apply the
rule and you see remarkable things that
happen you look at them and you say this
could have been invented 2000 years ago
how come it wasn't and okay you feel
good about the fact that well i managed
to invent it
usually the real reason why one managed
to invent it and it took a couple
thousand years is because there's some
sort of overall context there's some set
of other things that one understands
that make it worthwhile to think about
those kinds of things and that hadn't
existed in the past
but uh it is always interesting just
invented
sort of
as a result of a particular person doing
things there are other things where
occasionally the world gets to a certain
point
and then the same thing is invented um
because there's some ambient knowledge
in the world the same thing is invented
three times sort of in the same year um
just because that's kind of the stage
that the world has reached
um
but uh
so
yeah so i don't know the i about
specifically about pyramids i don't know
um
let's see
um
well let's look here
um
gosh
it's a question from dougie
does the double helix shape in dna show
up anywhere else in nature
interesting question
um
you know the primary
feature
of
you know dna has this helical form
um
i mean that's it's that's its most
obvious feature
but then
you know an actual piece of dna like
like human dna is a meter long
but it's in every one of our cells so it
certainly isn't that long thin thing
that's just coiled around in a spiral
helix type shape it's all curled up in a
tertiary structure that has uh which has
all kinds of pieces and there are all
kinds of issues about whether it gets
knotted and so on and and quite likely
some of the functionality that
some of it is known that some of the
functionality of the dna actually
depends on the way in which it gets
curled up like that
so i mean this this idea
of kind of the the double helix and the
concept so just to explain
dna
it's the molecule
that
uh
is has a surprising feature that that
one molecule can store lots of
information and that's how we pass our
genetic information on
and there is a copy of our dna in every
cell in our bodies
and dna
has a
uh the way it works is
there are these clumps these bases that
are clumps of i don't know how many
about 20 atoms 15 20 atoms
and there are four kinds a t c and g
and um they uh along the backbone of dna
you have the sequence you know a t t c g
g whatever it is some some long sequence
for us humans they're all together six
billion of those base pairs that encode
the way that we should build proteins
and create molecules that make us up
but in any case the the thing that is
the case is that the chemistry of dna is
such that you can kind of switch in
any of those a at c and g
on this backbone and the the kind of you
can make a molecule in which you can
have any sequence there most molecules
you know you'll have a particular set of
atoms in that molecule and that's the
way it'll be you don't get to kind of
mix and match
uh kind of clumps of of atoms in the
molecule
their other sort of a simpler version of
something like dna is polymer molecules
like pvc polyvinyl chloride or i think
nylon as an example of this also
um
uh molecules where there's a single unit
a single collection of atoms and just
repeats repeats repeats over and over
again and that gives you this long
stringy molecule
um and that's a that's an ordinary
polymer
uh dna is sort of technically referred
to as a heteropolymer it's a polymer
where there's repeating units it doesn't
have to be the same unit repeating many
times instead it can be these four
different possible units and they can
repeat kind of in any order one chooses
and what what their
uh what that sequence is is where the
information where the genetic
information is stored
now dna is this double helix because
well the fact that it forms a helix
is um
a
is a feature
of the backbone of the dna molecule and
uh you're probing pieces of chemistry i
do not know well
um
and uh i think it's a phosphate i think
phosphorus is some kind of in the
backbone and i'm sorry to say i don't i
can't immediately tell you how that
works
what i can tell you is that um the the
um there's a strand dna always has has
two strands
and uh if you have an a on one strand
there's always a t on the complementary
strand if there's a c on one strand
there's always a g on the complementary
strand and so dna essentially has these
two a positive and a negative copy of a
single dna molecule has a sort of
positive and negative copy of your
genetic information
and the the trick that dna uses and that
life uses
is that you can essentially copy a dna
molecule by having those two strands
unzip from each other so they become
something where there's just an a and it
doesn't have a pairing up t on the other
side and then that single strand can
then be refilled with a second strand
complementary strand that then has for
every a it has a t for every g it has a
c and so on um and that's that's how
replication happens is that the dna
unzips during a cell division it unzips
and then refills its complementary
strand from uh from material in that
that's provided in the in the
environment so to speak
and so
so that's the sense in which it is a a
a double helix so to speak
i think the helical shape is not
probably the most significant feature
and i'm not sure exactly what
uh functional significance it has i
think it just
is a helix just because
the way that the backbone is set up
is is such that it it doesn't it just
doesn't make a straight back on um just
by the nature of the the atoms that form
that backbone i don't think there's any
great significance to that
um when you
um when you
you know when you deal with dna there's
always the three prime direction and the
five prime direction which describe the
the sort of the outer side and the inner
side of the helix
and uh if you uh like you know i myself
got my whole genome sequence back in
2010 actually i've had it sequenced
several times since then just for uh
just because i'm a collector of data but
um when i'm curious whether you know
some newly published finding about
genetics
whether i have some variant of some
particular gene or not
i'll go and i'll look at my genome and
it's just a series of you know
language it's just a string
of characters ac gt et cetera et cetera
et cetera and you always have to it's
always a little tricky to go and see you
know somebody publishes a paper that
says if you've got attcg
in this section of this particular gene
then
uh you'll have brown eyes or something
then
uh to recognize to to find out what part
of your genome actually that is because
see the thing is everybody's genome is
slightly different there's six billion
base pairs altogether but we all have
um many millions of base pairs that
differ um between uh between different
people
and sometimes there'll be additions to
the genome sometimes there'll be
subtractions so you can't just say
this particular at position
you know three million seven hundred
thousand four hundred and seventeen
there should be an a
you can't really say that because
somewhere upstream of that you may very
well have all kinds of insertions and
deletions relative to kind of the the
default standard genome that that term
that exists so you have to be a little
bit trickier to look at flanking
sequences of oh i have this you know
this sequence of letters only because of
this place on the genome so i kind of
know where this is going to be and so on
and it's always tricky to get the right
side of the of the double helix
now this question about whether there
are other self-replicating molecules
well we don't know of any others
um
you can have
uh
sort of
modified versions of of dna and so on
but in terms of of completely different
chemistry to make a self-replicating
molecule there aren't examples known
they've got to be examples
it's just we haven't been quite
imaginative enough yet in in chemistry
to have come up with them now people
wonder you know in the origins of life
on earth it's pretty remarkable we ended
up with this molecule that so
successfully can replicate itself and
people kind of wonder how it came to be
that way
and i think the general uh
common belief is that in things like
clays so a clay is something where
there's sort of a
a kind of a matrix of mud and um there's
there's kind of other minerals that are
in that clay and one can imagine a
situation in which there's sort of a
solid
template
that
creates molecules
um so with dna what's what ultimately
happens with the dna it gets some you
know the rna um gets makes copies of
what's on the dna and then the rna is
used as a as a template to specify
you know uh
essentially
a unit by unit amino acid by amino acid
how to make a protein and you know we
are made from i don't know 30 50 000
different kinds of proteins which are
specified by our dna but so for us
we are making molecules to order
by having on the ribosomes in our cells
take in um that there's uh
the the the uh rna that is transcribed
from the dna is specifying the sequence
of units the sequence of amino acids
that will be extruded from the ribosome
to make uh proteins so our proteins are
just sequences of these amino acids so
the question is is there any other way
that you can in a templated fashion make
molecules and the most obvious kind of
thing to do is to have a solid template
a template which is that a molecular
scale is going to say you know put this
atom here put that atom there and what
the way that the atoms get put there is
well the atoms are floating around a
liquid or something like that and if
that solid template
has a particular form has particular
electrical properties or something at
that particular place then oh an atom of
this type or a or a radical group of
atoms will tend to bind will tend to be
attracted to that place another one will
be attracted to another place and so on
and one can imagine a situation in which
one would kind of be making a molecule
on a template on something like the clay
now you know are molecules made on
templates well yes they are
that's actually a lot of how biology
works
and how uh also a lot of industrial
chemistry works
um in
in catalysts so normally you have a
chemical reaction what is a chemical
reaction you have a bunch of molecules
they're all floating around like in a
liquid most chemical reactions take
place in the liquid phase
because that's where molecules are
fairly dense
um unlike a gas where they're much more
less dense and liquid they're dense but
they're just always bouncing around
randomly and most of the time when
molecules bounce around liquid they just
bounce off each other but if there is
the potential for a chemical reaction
then occasionally when two molecules hit
each other they'll be arranged in just
the right orientation that the molecules
will exchange electrons they'll they'll
change their configuration they'll have
a they'll interact they'll produce a new
molecule and that's what a chemical
reaction is
is molecules colliding they get close
enough in the right orientation so that
they can have electrical or they can
sort of exchange electrons to change the
structure of bonds between the atoms and
so on okay so
that can happen just by two molecules
just randomly crashing into each other
but the other possibility is that the
the the first atom can be
for example can can sit inside some some
place on a surface
um some particular uh sort of patterning
of some surface at the molecular scale
can sort of uh have a molecule just just
sit in that hole let's say
and then another molecule will come
along
and uh will fit itself into the into
that first molecule
and so that's uh that's how catalysts
tend to work that a catalyst most common
case is that it's some solid
and
it
the surface of that solid has a certain
roughness or certain features which
cause the molecules to kind of get they
they get attracted to the surface they
sit on the surface and they are by the
by the features on the surface those
molecules are oriented in a particular
way and oriented in just the right way
so that when the molecules that are
floating around on the liquid or
something come there those they will be
more likely to uh to sort of attach in
the right way and produce a chemical
reaction so that's what happens in lots
of industrial chemistry
um and it's what happens i don't know
catalystic converters for example it's
pretty common to use metals like
platinum and so on um because they have
certain features of their surface their
crystal structure leads to certain
features of their surface which are
convenient for kind of aligning
molecules the right way
um the
the other case that happens is in
biology where enzymes um enzymes are
molecules that sort of
catalyze reactions they're typically big
protein molecules and they'll have a
certain shape and the shape will have
certain holes in it certain valleys
certain peaks and so on and what will
tend to happen is that one molecule will
kind of um be be attached to that enzyme
in that particular way and then could
set things up so that it is more likely
that a reaction will happen and and
often the rate
of the change in the rate of reactions
associated with catalysts or enzymes or
whatever is huge it's factors of uh you
know the billion and so on it really
matters that these molecules aren't just
bouncing around randomly in random
orientations but they're actually sort
of arranged in the right configuration
to undergo a chemical reaction
so
uh
let's see
it's a question here
oh i was going to maybe just finish on
this question about some
molecules that can copy themselves i
think that
that
this
feature i mean
it seems easier to kind of arrange this
to happen at the level of a molecule and
prints itself on a solid and kind of
patterns the solid in a certain way and
then something else comes along and use
that uses that template in the solid to
to make another copy it seems a bit
easier than the case with dna where it's
kind of molecules molecule type type
stuff but but one doesn't know
and uh uh it's it's interesting to kind
of um
um
imagine if we were going to redo life
how would we set it up and for example
in uh
as we start thinking about molecular
computing
uh it's of great interest to try and see
how we
replicate some of the kind of methods
that are used by by living systems to to
kind of uh do things with molecules
um which leads us to a question here
from aaron
are there any examples of logical gates
being built out of chemical reactions
um
what breakthroughs are needed to achieve
this how many gates are needed for a
programming language like c
okay so
yes people have made logical gates out
of chemical reactions
though usually they've used dna to do it
which is kind of a kind of a
a you know you're building a giant tower
to achieve something comparatively
simple
um the most common case
is that they'll use dna
they'll use the fact that dna has this
matching property
to make kind of tiles out of dna so that
which have the property that they only
match in certain configuration and
therefore you can get you can arrange
for sort of to make a progressive jigsaw
puzzle that will do things like
corresponds to uh to a logical gate
um now i i have to say i i think that's
an unbelievably over complicated way to
do it
and uh in fact some things i'm looking
at right now
might lead one to much simpler ways to
make the equivalent of logical gates out
of uh molecules and interactions between
molecules of that just yesterday we were
doing a live stream about molecular
computing
and sub-chemistry where we're talking
about some things which might be a
run-up to that we didn't talk about
logical gates actually maybe we should
have done just to explain to people what
logical gates are
um
when uh this is kind of an idea from the
original uh origination of logic back in
antiquity um but uh sort of was cleaned
up in the 1800s and then cleaned up even
more when electronics became
popular
but the idea is you've got um
you've got p and q
and you say
uh p and q what is p and q it means if
both p is true and q is true then the
result p and q is also true
or you can say p or q if either p or q
is true then the result is true
otherwise it's false
and so
when you go to um uh well it used to be
the case when you go to an electronics
store you can buy an and gate so to
speak um you know i don't think that's
really a thing anymore because these
days there are microprocessors that have
you know a billion of these kinds of
gates sort of already printed on them
and you don't really get the individual
and gate type thing
but
uh you can make
um
you can arrange
sort of combinations of those gates to
represent any kind of logical expression
so
um and by having sort of uh by by having
memory and feeding things back and so on
you can use that to make any computation
you want
now the thing that was discovered about
110 years ago now
is that all these different logical
gates you know and gates and all gates
and not gates and exclusive or gates and
so on
all of those gates can be made from
combinations of just one kind of gate a
nand gate so what does a nand gate do if
you have p nand q
it's the not of p and q
so for example nand let's say
uh
p and q are both true
okay so p and q is true but nand p nand
q is false
so if if uh if true is one and false is
zero so that means that one one
will be zero one one
going into a nand gate will give an
output of zero uh one zero going into a
nand gate will give an output of one
and so on
but so it turns out to be possible to
make anything out of combinations of
nand gates any logic operation of
combinations of nand gates like uh well
let's see what is um
oh my gosh i should be able to do this
man the p and p
i think is not p
um and and you can keep going you know
nand of p of nand of q and r and so on
will make an and and so on some of them
are kind of complicated but you can you
can make anything out of an and gate so
if you can make a nand gate from
chemistry then you can make any logical
operation from chemistry and it's a good
question whether there's a an easy way
to do that by just looking at chemical
reactions good thing for us to look at
actually
um
the uh
if you want to make
kind of a
uh
a programming language
well you actually don't need you need a
you need a memory you need the ability
to store bits of information but you
don't actually need a lot of uh
structure
in the kind of in the gates that you
have
i mean a typical microprocessor these
days might have a billion nand gates on
it
but in principle you don't need all that
many nand gates you're you're uh
at the cost of having a more complicated
program having more complicated software
you can have a vastly simpler setup like
for example uh well i had this idea
years ago that of the very simplest
possible turing machine a turing machine
is kind of idealization of computation
that's based on you can base it on logic
operations if you want to logic
operations plus memory turns out you can
have a turing machine with just six sort
of cases for its logic
um that is universal is capable of any
computation you want um and that's the
very simplest possibility but it's
really simple and as something that
might be made of molecules it's really
quite a plausible thing and actually we
didn't talk about that in our discussion
like your computing yesterday and we
should have done it
um
anyway so let's see
all right let's see
baker asks is it necessary to have
supercomputers to do meaningful
biomolecule level simulations
so
the question is you've got a molecule
it's made of a bunch of atoms
you can usually you know people often
draw these kind of ball and stick
diagrams representing molecules
they're an approximation they're not
perfect
in reality
uh
a slightly better model would be to say
they're these atoms and they're
connected by kind of springs to other
atoms and so if you take that molecule
and you kind of kick it it will vibrate
around and one can actually measure the
vibrations of molecules is an important
thing to do in recognizing molecules bin
spectroscopy and so on um but uh
even that's just an approximation the
true story is a whole bunch of fancy
quantum mechanics and a bunch of fancy
mathematics
it's super difficult if you go to the
level of that fancy mathematics to work
out given a certain set of atoms
what will the configuration of the
molecule made of that atoms be that's
really difficult the limit of what
people can do is maybe 100 or 200 atoms
to be able to do that kind of
calculation from scratch using all the
fancy mathematics of quantum mechanics
and say given these atoms what will a
molecule made of those atoms be like
so usually once dealing with
approximations one's dealing with the
kinds of things that happen with
millions or billions of of uh of atoms
that might well millions of atoms that
might exist in a protein for example
one is uh when is not able to do things
at the level of the perfect mathematics
and quantum mechanics that apply to sort
of individual atoms someone's using an
approximation one's using an
approximation where one says that the
force between atoms is governed by a
certain force law
but even with that approximation it's
still difficult to work out what this a
million atom thing will will do
and a long-running issue is when you
have proteins which are made from
millions of atoms how will the proteins
fold up the proteins are made in a line
they they're they're they come off the
the transcription of the dna sequence
and there is a you know a line of amino
acids but proteins in practice most
proteins fold up some proteins don't
some some proteins like the ones in our
muscles are long and stringy but many
proteins fold themselves up in this kind
of globular structure
and it's it's been a long time issue to
figure out how that folding works
even though the the um uh the kind of in
principle we kind of know the physics of
what causes that folding we know it at
the level of quantum mechanics that's
super difficult we level up the know it
at the level of force laws that's just
difficult and for a long time it was
sort of an unsolved computational
problem how do you how does a protein
fold up there were typically two schools
of thought one is you just compute the
forces and you see how the thing would
actually fold the other is you just look
at how other proteins folded you try and
extrapolate
you kind of just try and use pattern
matching effectively to say i've seen a
protein that looks like this and it
folded like that
what's happened in the last couple of
years
is that with machine learning methods
pretty much the
we'll see how the other proteins folded
method has won out and that's now
allowing one to do pretty good protein
folding calculations probably what's
really happening there though is that
there are particular patterns of folding
that we've never really identified but
which the computer is successfully
identifying we do know that proteins
will often fold up in helices actually
alpha helices
or beta sheets um but uh you know there
are probably some other motifs into
which they fold that are the real things
that these machine learning methods are
keying into to figure out sort of what
the overall structure of the protein
should be
but
to know how the protein will behave like
if you kick the protein a certain way
how will it blob around what will it do
or if some other
molecule comes close to the protein and
and starts pushing pieces of it away and
maybe there's a an active site that
opens up and and things bind to it to
know how that all works that's really
hard
um and uh you know if you look at
simulations of molecules um there's a
nice um uh our former company touch
press
a nice book by our
um by uh theodore gray um who was um
uh long time involved with our company
still involved with our company um uh
the
most notable in the world perhaps for
for creating the um the original
notebook interface for language and so
on back in 1987 or so anyway theodore
theo gray
produced a book about molecules
that you can get on the ipad um that is
rather lovely because it actually has
sort of realistic molecules that you can
touch with your fingers and pull the
atoms apart and see the molecule kind of
flopping around as molecules flop around
it's it's kind of about the only
application i've ever seen for the ipad
where the fact that you can actually put
10 fingers down and sort of touch 10
different atoms is useful
but any case so one of the things you
kind of learn from playing around with
that is that there are molecules that
are really quite rigid and there are
molecules that are very very floppy and
there are molecules where the sections
of the molecule are very floppy and can
twist around in other parts that are
quite rigid and so on but when you have
a big biomolecule and the question is
what does it do when you deform it in
some way really hard to tell and so so
for example there are um efforts to make
special purpose computers to do that um
um they're
a whole friend of mine has has
built many such things um
the uh
but it's really hard and they're a lot
of clever there's a lot of cleverness to
do with
how you actually
do the computations for the molecular
dynamics and whether you can do them in
parallel whether you can look at uh
have different parts of a computer
different different computers connected
together where one computer is dealing
with the atoms over here in the molecule
another computer is dealing with the
atoms over here in a molecule and run
those two computers in parallel whether
you have to sequentially look at first
these atoms then these atoms than these
atoms and so on
but the question of whether there's a
better way to do it
um
and perhaps using the well i've seen it
before machine learning type methods i
think it's still unclear it's still sort
of an open question it's quite possible
there will be ways to do that one
problem with the i've seen it before
method of saying what happens is it
turns out you haven't seen it before
you might get a totally wrong answer if
you've got something where it sort of
looks kind of like something you've seen
before but look there's something a
little different and you didn't key into
that difference properly
people wonder whether you might uh maybe
i shouldn't get into this particular
rabbit hole but people wonder whether
you can use quantum computers to do
simulations of quantum
molecules and so on well the answer is
uh almost by definition the answer was
yes the problem is
that
to know what the quantum computer did
and this is sort of a the the the um
the nasty underbelly of quantum
mechanics
yes the thing can inside it can
quantumly figure out what's going on but
us humans
think definite things happen in the
world and so all those parallel threads
of what might have happened in quantum
mechanics we have to resolve those
to actually come out with an answer and
that process of resolution is is hard we
don't even know how hard and so i think
that it isn't such a it's not such a
great idea to say oh we'll just make a
quantum computer do it because yes the
quantum computer is quantum mechanical
like the molecule is and so yes inside
it's all great but to read out the
answer is a whole challenge
so
uh so so i mean
um
they could ask this question about is it
is it necessary to have supercomputers
to do biomolecule simulations
there are some places where it isn't so
necessary for example rna
it folds up in ways that are have
definite motifs and are computable
without a very fancy supercomputer
proteins have been hard
um the dynamics of proteins has also
been hard um i think that it could very
well be the case
that over time we discover sort of the
patterns by which these things work
and we may be able to
rather than having to trace every single
atom individually we may be able to say
oh we just need to look at this
collective thing of a thousand atoms we
now know what we need to look at about
those thousand atoms to figure out how
they'll interact with another thousand
atoms and that may make it much uh
less computational intensive to do these
computations
let's see
um
some other things here
uh
oh boy a lot of interesting questions
here
um
asks
what life forms have arbitrary
differences between individuals and what
life forms have meaningfully quotes
unique individuals
it's an interesting question
i think
that um
uh
well
when you have something like a virus
which has a certain dna sequence rna
sequence
like our unfriendly covered virus
has an rna sequence is about 29 000 base
pairs long
and you say
um which particular collide virus do you
have
well there are all these variants all
these strains
within a particular strain at 29 000
base pairs you may have an identical
sequence of
base pairs
but between different strains you'll see
differences in those base pairs and and
one might have seen those plots
um of sort of the genealogy of the
viruses
um a bunch made by a former employee of
ours actually he was not a well-known
virologist
um
the uh showing kind of the tree by which
um
the uh
uh
by which this sort of divergence of you
know first there was one virus and then
there was a mutation in that virus a
change in the genetic sequence of the
virus
and then that would then there were two
different viruses that sort of came from
that one and you end up with this whole
kind of tree of variance and so on and
there are there are great many variants
at this point among viruses so those
those have sort of within within each
variant the viruses may be identical but
uh but between variants they'll be
different
um so
when
uh
when you have different individuals so
for example for identical twins
humans let's say who have identical dna
uh precisely identical dna not every
feature of those twins will be
identified identical the details of
their fingerprints the detailed folding
of their ears or their brains or
whatever else will be different it may
have some of the same overall features
but some of that
detail
was the result of of features of the
development of that human being
and it won't be identical it's not it's
epigenetic it's it's something beyond
the genetics of that human and so
individuality arises by virtue of sort
of the actual growth of the organism as
well as at the level of dna
and
there are some organisms where
the placement of cells
if it's a multicellular organism is
always the same and there's some
organisms like us where even between
identical twins the details of where
cells are placed will be different you
know you do a retinal scan of those
twins it'll be a completely different
pattern of blood vessels at the back of
their eyes although maybe there's some
overall features that were inherited but
the detailed way in which the blood
vessels sort of filled out the
capillaries filled out
the um the back of the eye will be
different
um there are organisms
where that isn't the case whether where
the cells always form in the same way
so for example c elegans the nematode
tiny worm
it has so how many is it about 2 000
cells in it
and
uh pretty much every nematode is the
same
the the cells are arranged in a
particular
structure a particular you know the the
mouth cell goes here and the brain cell
goes there
and so on and it's precisely determined
but when you get to larger organisms
that's no longer the case
and there will be
uh there'll be um features that are
um
the uh
um
um
uh that are
that are different between them
um between different different members
of the of the of the species so i'm
guessing i don't know exactly where the
dividing line is
when the fates of cells uh and the
locations of cells in the organism are
precisely determined it's bigger than 2
000 it's smaller than a trillion um my
guess is that by the time you're out of
the tens of thousands of cells you're at
the point where they're no longer where
it's no longer the case where the
overall form of where the cells go may
be determined but the particular cell by
cell arrangement is no longer precisely
determined there may be pieces like i
don't know the motors in a in a you know
for some kind of flagellum for some
little creature
that that may be very precise it almost
looks like a crystal it has its its
little molecular units arranged so
precisely but there are other parts and
even actually in us are there places in
us where things are arranged
kind of at that level of molecular
detail yeah i mean there's certainly
things
at
the level of
of small clusters of molecules where
that's the case but i think when it
comes to the large large-scale structure
of any of our organs or other kinds of
systems i don't think that's the way it
works i don't think it's precisely
determined in that way
um
well there's a question here for from a
non-mouse
um are darwin's survival of the fittest
evolution and machine learning all
basically the same thing
if not how do they differ
uh
well
so
let's see
the
the question of
a lot of these have to do with
you've got a certain set of constraints
how do you find the best way to satisfy
those constraints
for example
let's say
you are
trying to you've got some mountain scope
you've got some collection of hills and
valleys and so on and you're trying to
find where's the lowest point in this
mountainscape and you're just walking
around you're an ant on this or a person
on this mountainscape and you don't have
a topographic map or a gps or a
satellite or anything like that you're
just walking around on the mountains
trying to find where's the lowest point
and so then the question is how do you
best do that
and that's a problem of optimization
it's a problem how do you get how do you
get to the lowest point
um and you might say well i'm walking
down this mountain and i'm down and here
i can look up on all sides of me things
are going up so i'm at the lowest point
well that might not be true because it
might be one valley over there's a lower
point and if you but you'd have to go
over the mountain to get to that lower
point
and if all you're doing is to say am i
at the lowest point let me see whether
everything from me is up
then you wouldn't notice that still
lower point
and so
one approach
to
finding the lowest point is so-called
gradient descent you say wherever i am
pick the path that makes me go down the
fastest from where i am
and yes that will have the feature that
it will often lead you sort of down the
mountain as quickly as possible but it
might lead you to something which is in
one valley and not in another valley and
you might miss the lowest valley you
might find the local optimum but not the
global
you know all over the landscape optimum
so that's a that's a sort of a feature
there but
in
in many of these problems one's somehow
trying to find some kind of some kind of
optimum or at least better than the
other guy optimum
so biological evolution
what one's interested in is
uh that
one's one's organism so to speak one
species is going to be better if it's
somehow better suited to the environment
you know if
if it turns out you need to be able to
eat those leaves from the top of the
tree the longer your neck is the more
likely you are to be able to eat from
the top of the tree and to survive and
and have uh baby giraffes or whatever
um
and uh so
but the the thing you're trying to do
ultimately is to optimize things so that
you eat best from the top of the tree
so then the question is what is the best
strategy
for finding the type of organism that
would be able to eat or the type of
thing that would be able to eat from the
top of the tree
well
you could adopt a variety of different
strategies
biological evolution adopts a particular
strategy according to darwinian
evolution
it basically makes lots of variant
giraffes
and then each giraffe does its thing
and the giraffes that manage to eat best
from the top of the tree will have the
most
uh you know let's imagine will have the
most little giraffes and so the the
trait
of
uh being able to eat from the top of the
tree which is passed from giraffe to
baby giraffe so to speak
um will
tend to win out
um because one has uh the because
the the
the more successful organism the one
that is more optimal will have more
children and therefore there will be
more likelihood that any that they'll be
it's its genetics its program will tend
to win out against other ones
so that that's kind of the approach in
in darwinian evolution you have in
parallel lots of little giraffes and
some of them do better than others
in something like machine learning
you're also interested in finding
uh it's not the construction of the
giraffe you're interested in it's for
example the construction of a neural net
and you're asked the question
which neural net with its little
detailed connections inside it will best
recognize cats from dogs and you want to
keep tweaking the neural net until it
does the best at recognizing cats from
dogs
the strategy that's used there is a
little different
um the strategy that's used there the
most common one is back propagation
where you kind of see well how far off
are you
and then you kind of go back more in an
engineering way and say well what do i
need to change to make me uh go uh sort
of more in that direction
so
actually maybe i should should make a
um
a uh
okay so there's a there's a there's a
sort of commonality and difference i
mean the particular approach of natural
selection of having lots of baby
giraffes and so on and seeing which one
wins that's not doesn't tend to be in
detail the way that one does things in
machine learning
there are methods for doing machine
learning which are much more like that
but the most common ones with neural
networks that isn't the most common way
to do things instead it's a much more
sort of organized um you know
it's it it made the thing go off in this
direction we can figure out how to tweak
it so that it doesn't go as much in that
direction it's a more kind of
engineering solution but at the biggest
level at the sort of broadest level
you're still
trying to find an optimum you're trying
to find the best neural nets the best
distinguishes cats from dogs you're
trying to find the best genetics for the
giraffe that best eats from the top of
the tree and so on
and
in both cases you're actually making
small incremental changes typically
typically not not
we don't completely know about
biological evolution but
it seems like it's usually the case that
the giraffe will like have a slightly
longer you know it's the child through
off will have a slightly longer neck a
slightly shorter leg a slightly
different you know mouth structure or
whatever else
um that it seems like biological
evolution mostly just makes these small
incremental changes it's kind of almost
like that idea you're walking around in
the mountain you're making small moves
to get closer to the
the the bottom of the mountain or
whatever um we don't completely know
whether biological evolution sometimes
makes bigger jumps we can't really see
necessarily we can uh you know in the
fossil record for example we often will
see well first there were these kinds of
creatures and then there were those
kinds of creatures but actually there
was a million years between those two
types of creatures showing up in the
fossil record we don't completely know
what happened in between and sometimes
what happens is there's a gradual change
like a creature that was walking on four
legs will gradually change its mechanics
and then one day one of those creatures
will realize gosh i can walk around on
just two legs and then and then things
will rapidly change it and that's why so
perhaps in the fossil record it looks as
if it went from four-legged to
two-legged very quickly even though it
had been sort of a gradual process of
one set of legs getting longer and
shorter and then suddenly it could
become two-legged type thing
um and so
we don't completely know we we know that
in things like viruses there's some sort
of violent changes of genetics where
there are crossovers where they're where
sort of pieces of a viral genome will
get exchanged with other with other
organisms where a big chunk of genome
will get exchanged that's probably
happened with us as well between viruses
and us um there's probably been a bunch
we know of some examples of that of
exchanges with different organisms with
us where big chunks of genome get
changed
but the full story of how that works is
really not not known i mean we can we
can get some idea of that by looking at
some
uh
microorganisms
and asking the question you have a plate
for example you have some particular
kind of bacteria and you have an
antibiotic and the antibiotic is killing
off that those bacteria but as you go on
the bacteria will evolve you'll get
mutations to the bacteria and eventually
those bacteria might become resistant to
the antibiotic and so then you'll see on
this plate a different you know
different bacteria maybe you can stain
them in different colors different
bacteria will kind of grow past the
antibiotic then you put a stronger
antibiotic on and then then you'll kill
off those bacteria but then eventually a
little finger will
will evolve beyond that where they
evolved to be uh resistant to that
antibiotic and so on and and i don't
know to what extent i mean that the
pictures i've certainly seen of that it
kind of seems like
there are sort of occasional discoveries
so to speak made by the bacteria
occasional kind of jumps
where the bacteria sort of discover some
feature they they have some they make
some new protein or something like that
that allows them to be resistant to
bacteria i don't think we really know
with clarity what the the sort of the
gradualness versus jumpiness of
biological evolution is really like um
because sometimes that the difference
between what happens in the program and
what happens in the final organism the
genotype and the program versus the
phenotype of the final organism we don't
that transformation is a very difficult
one and we don't necessarily know
what effect even us
small changes on the genome will have on
the actual form of the organism and that
that doesn't help things
so uh the the um the the details of
whether to the extent to which both
biological evolution
and machine learning um
and uh
uh and optimization the extent to which
all three of these use sort of gradual
incremental change uh they all do to
some extent we don't know in the case of
biology we don't completely know
um in the case of optimization of this
like find the minimum on the mountain
um
there are certain shapes of mountains
certain mathematical forms where vastly
more efficient techniques can be used
than this kind of just move down the
gradient vector and keep going in fact
that was one of the things in
operations research and linear
programming uh something we invented in
the 1930s and 1940s
um
sort of critical to the efficiency of
things like factories and so on it's
like if you're trying to make this
number of widgets
how many of this piece of raw material
that piece of raw material do you need
and how does that all sort of fit
together
that becomes a problem
of linear inequalities um you're taking
sums of variables uh and and
and so on with with uh multiplied by
constants you're saying that's going to
be greater than this we've got to have
at least this number of widgets have to
be in stock for us to go on and make
these other widgets and so on and so
there were it became of great interest
for many kinds of problems to uh both
both sort of uh in terms of sort of
supply chain type things and in terms of
things like how do we optimize the
routes for an airline things like this
uh those became problems of linear
programming of these solving these
inequalities and very big systems of
linear inequalities millions sometimes
of those
and what happened was that in the
1940s i guess
methods were invented that were not just
oh you just incrementally changed things
until you got a good answer
which actually hadn't been done because
things were still being done by hand
that wasn't a very convenient thing to
do by hand instead the so-called simplex
method was invented where it's just like
um
uh you um
you could just go
kind of almost immediately you go to the
sort of corner that optimizes things um
and so that was a method that wasn't
incremental and there are other methods
of so-called convex optimization which
also aren't incremental like that so it
isn't the case that all optimization
happens incrementally sort of a small
step at a time but um some of the ones
that seem to happen in nature for
example that's a that's a convenient
trick that nature has learnt
and it's also something which tends to
happen in in some types of machine
learning also
all right maybe um
one more
uh
one two more here
um
architect asks about um
the formation of buckyballs
so um
uh buckyballs are a form of carbon
that
in which the most common form is is
carbon 60 in which there are 60 carbon
atoms arranged in kind of at the seams
of a soccer ball
and um
uh the thing that
when you have a bunch of carbon atoms
you can kind of pack them together in
different ways so the two most famous
ways are graphite and diamond
and graphite the carbon atoms are kind
of packed in in layers
um and uh in in diamond
both graphite and diamond are pure
carbon just a bunch of carbon atoms
diamond
the
the carbon atoms are arranged in a
particular packing pattern that isn't in
layers um that is a particular structure
usually called the diamond crystal
structure um it's a it's a repeating
structure but it isn't a layered
structure it's a little bit more like
the kind of structure you get if you
look at how fruit is piled up in a
grocery store it isn't exactly that
structure but it's something similar to
that
um so those are two forms of carbon that
one that i knew that had been known for
a long time
question was are there any other ways to
put pure carbon atoms together well
turns out there are and actually this
wasn't discovered until the
1970s possibly even 1980s
and it was discovered by pretty fancy
techniques
involving kind of analyzing the
structure of molecules and so on it's
not easy because molecules are really
small you can't just directly look at
them you have to use indirect techniques
using x-rays or using other kinds of um
techniques you have to indirectly deduce
the structure of molecules
um to and and it's often quite
challenging to figure out what they
might be
but so in the case of of of carbon
people wondered could you have carbon
arranged itself in different ways in
ways that weren't just
graphite or
um
or diamond and people sort of played
around with that and they managed to
make some examples where there were
these carbons and a bunch of hydrogens
hanging off them and so on
but then it was discovered that actually
in common soot there are carbons
clusters of carbon atoms that get made
they're actually four molecules and they
are these molecules that are things like
these cages like the c60 molecule that
is a bucket ball a buckyball is is
the combination of of um hexagonal faces
and pentagonal faces kind of the way
that a soccer ball works if you had all
hexagons if you just you can they'll
just form they'll just tile the plane
it's just like a you know a bathroom
tiling or something where you have a
bunch of hexagonal tiles they're just a
flat on the plane if you have pentagons
on the other hand if you just try and
arrange pentagons together they're not
flat at all
just put a bunch of pentagons together
they will arrange themselves
specifically into a dodecahedron
a 12-faced object 12-phase polyhedron
that's the only way you can you can put
a bunch of pentagons together but if you
mix hexagons and heptagons hexagons make
something flat pentagons make something
curl up if you have mostly hexagons but
just a few pentagons
then you can make something which has
sort of an arbitrary curvature you can
have something where just have just a
very very few pentagons it'll be almost
flat but just a little bit curled up the
more pentagons the more curled up it
will be so you can get different bucky
balls that have different kinds of
curvature which are like the less curved
the more flat it is it's more hexagons
less pentagons and so on
so buckyballs have this feature that
they actually made in pretty easily in
in soot and so on
um
they can be refined in a variety of ways
um but uh uh they're not so hard to make
um now people have found that there are
different uh structures of carbon you
can also make graphene and you can make
uh carbon nanotubes uh carbon nanotube
is kind of like a a cylinder of carbon
where as you go around the cylinder
you've got these pentagon hexagon type
things like in a buckyball but they're
arranged to make a a cylinder um carbon
nanotubes are pretty interesting they're
very strong
and they're very good electrical
conductors and people talk about weaving
them to make things that are strong
enough to even be able to lasso a
satellite in orbit around the earth and
have like a space elevator where you can
go from the surface of the earth
and to orbit i'm not quite sure if that
works um i mean nobody's built one yet
but i'm not quite sure even if
theoretically yet
um carbon nanotubes are strong enough
and sort of uh spinnable
together um in such a way that you could
do that um but any case that's kind of
the idea of um uh
and people imagine
some some things uh been made with with
wires being made from um
carbon nanotubes and then crossing over
and making gates and you can sort of
imagine making some different form of
electrical circuit which is made sort of
more at the molecular scale with just
these pieces of carbon and electrons
kind of going through at that and that's
kind of a a coming attraction of kind of
a new form of electronic-like device
um
let's see
uh
oh i'm just going to going to pick one
more here
um and then i really should get going
from www
um asking how are gemstones formed and
how can we model gem features colors
textures
asterism and isotropy everything
okay so what is a gemstone gemstone is a
crystal
well as a crystal a crystal is a regular
arrangement of atoms
and there are
uh
oh my gosh how many
16 bravais lattices i remembered
correctly
um
um
um
the uh
um
uh there there are definite there are
different ways that you can arrange
atoms uh to make a regular crystal but
there are only a limited number of ways
because
there are only certain kinds of
symmetries that you can have so so for
example
um
just like i well if you
imagine um
i think how to
uh
if you imagine putting together
identical objects let's say you have
cubes you can put together identical
cubes and they'll be in a cubic lattice
let's say you pick
uh
some other kind of shape um it's not so
easy to find shapes that you can put
together identically
um to uh to form uh in in space but
there are other ones
um
the let's say a snub cube is another one
and ah
there are a bunch of these um
that are not not such common shapes
they're not the ordinary polyhedra so to
speak they're not the ordinary regular
platonic solids there are other kinds of
solids and i'm
i'm suddenly slipping my mind i have a
nice picture of these in my book new
kind of science
um and uh uh
but i'm i'm um they don't have
particularly common names but anyway
they're a different polyhedra but you
can arrange them in space
in a very regular way so it's just one
you know every every section looks the
same
but they don't
um they don't have the same overall
structure as for example cubes arrange
together so for example one thing you
can notice is if you have a cube the
cube has six faces that means there are
six cubes that are adjacent to that cube
but actually there are other
arrangements of things where you for
example can have 12 things adjacent to a
given thing that's a different structure
anyways there are limited set of these
possible crystal structures and those
determine
the the uh the way that the atoms and
sometimes uh okay so some gemstones
uh they're not something like diamond
consists just of
uh
of carbon atoms
something like quartz has
silicon oxide is that right
um it has it doesn't just have one kind
of atom in it
there are there are other kinds of
crystals which can just be copper's one
atom but there are there are crystals in
which there is a a uh the unit cell of
the crystal the thing that repeats
contains more than one atom another
example is table salt sodium chloride
has sodium and chlorine atoms arranged
in a particular in that particular case
they're in a cubic arrangement um but so
you have this unit cell which is made of
some collection of atoms and then the
crystal is a repetition of that unit
cell many many times and
there are only a limited number of kinds
of symmetries of repetitions that you
can have
but the unit cells can be of different
forms and different gemstones have
different unit cells and they'll
typically have silicon aluminum
oxygen
sometimes some
more obscure metals iron
manganese
all these kinds of things and any given
uh type of gem
will have a particular
um
a particular
set of
of um a particular sort of chemical
formula in effect a particular set of
atoms that form its unit cell
now
uh it's a little tricky because the
internal structure of the crystal will
have some particular form that has a
particular way of arranging the unit
cells
the outer boundary of the crystal
may not
uh
has a complicated relationship to what's
on going on inside so for example for
diamonds
uh
the it's it's a big art to cut diamonds
in different ways
whenever you cut a diamond what you're
doing is you're cleaving between atoms
you're you're cutting through a plane
but between planes of atoms you don't
it's much harder if you wanted to cut in
a diamond if you are going to sort of uh
go oh you're trying to
break between these two atoms and those
two atoms in different ways that's a
much harder cut to make than if you're
kind of slicing between planes of atoms
but there are many different slicings
that you can make between planes of
atoms and different cuts of diamonds
correspond to different choices of those
slicings those slicings are labeled
technically they're called miller
indices um they are labeled by kind of
which
uh
sort of how many atoms across do you go
for how many atoms down more or less in
this crystal lattice and that labels
different planes that you can use to to
slice a crystal on
um and so for example with diamond
people make up these things so brilliant
cuts of diamond which are particular
ways of slicing the diamond so that
light because diamond has a very high
refractive index about 2.7 light when
light gets into diamond it will tend to
bounce around inside the diamond and if
you arrange the angles at the outer
outer border of the diamond in just the
right way by cutting it the right way
you'll have many reflections of the
light inside the diamond which makes the
diamond sparkle
so in any case the when you see a
gemstone that's been cut
it's been cut along these cleavage
planes in the crystal but the details of
how it's cut are often part of the story
of you know that's a cute gemstone type
of thing
so
the other thing about gemstones is they
tend to have well they have
imperfections because when the crystal
grew
it
uh the atoms were being arranged some
some crystals go very quickly some grow
slowly you can have a crystal of um
or like an alum crystal sodium
thiosulfate i think which grows like in
in moments you've got the whole crystal
um and you can have a copper sulfate
crystal i remember growing those when i
was a kid they're nice blue crystals and
you make this um uh this liquid solution
of copper sulfate and as
the water kind of evaporates out you get
sort of a higher density of copper
sulfate and if you put a little string
in and you seed the crystal you can if
you do it right get this big parallel
pipe edge-shaped crystal coming out
that's this big blue copper sulfate
crystal and what happened there is the
the molecules of copper sulfate um you
know gradually attached to the growing
surface of the crystal you've got this
whole crystal but when a crystal is
growing uh or exists in in you know in
the ground or whatever else it's grown
in some some geological process
um often it won't form perfectly in any
of these situations even in the copper
sulphic crystal you go and the
little string and so on they typically
won't form perfectly there will be
little imperfections either
imperfections in the fact that the
crystal lattice doesn't align properly
there was a missing missing molecule or
something that caused a sort of a defect
maybe a screw dislocation where there's
a sequence of atoms in a kind of helical
shape that are missing other other kinds
of things like that
um or that are misplaced rather i should
say um but uh so there are defects in
the crystal there are places where you
can actually have an impurity in the
crystal some other substance that got
into the crystal as it was forming so
those are those are things that can
happen
the um the question of uh in their
natural habitat so to speak when
crystals form sometimes like quartz
crystals for example you'll often see
these very faceted shapes and so on um
and um
but other crystals they'll be kind of
messy on the the outer boundary will be
kind of messy and only when you cut them
or they look really sort of gemstone
like
another feature of gemstones is their
colors
and sometimes the very bright colors of
gemstones come from rather interesting
um
uh
um
uh
sort of phenomenon
that um
uh there are
uh what they're called color centers
think f centers i believe
that
so so normally
what makes the color of something what
makes the color of something is
if you start white light is a
combination of all the different colors
of the rainbow
and if you for example absorb from all
that from the white light that for
example is made by the sun if you absorb
all the blue light
then you'll have red left over if you
absorb all the red light you'll have
blue left over and so on
and so the question is
what colors of light get absorbed or not
by different kinds of crystals so a
diamond is more or less transparent
normally um but
the question of how it will and that
happens because
well in a diamond when a photon of light
comes into a diamond
it
it doesn't the the diamond is is sort of
letting through all those
all the different energies of photons
corresponding to all the different
colors and that's why it's transparent
but what can happen is
that a
a sort of a cage can be created within
the crystal in which there is an
imperfection
and an atom can be in that imperfection
and
what can happen is a photon comes in and
it hits that atom in the imperfection
and it causes that atom to be it makes
that atom sort of bounce around
and depending on sort of the size of the
imperfection the type of atom it is the
size of the cage and the type of atom it
can be a particular color
of a particular energy of photon a
particular color of light a particular
frequency of light
that will excite that atom
and that's why you can have these very
very specific colors of gemstones has to
do with that phenomenon and that's some
uh and that's what what what can happen
there there's a bit more detail to that
and there's some there's some
interesting quantum mechanics and so on
that goes along with how that excitation
of those atoms works in in those cases
but that's that's that basic phenomenon
um
i think
uh um there are so many other things
that happen in gemstones i mean in um
another common phenomenon is what's
called birefringence
um we talked about light you know
different colors of light getting
through or not getting through leading
to different um uh leading to the
appearance of different colors of
gemstone but nothing can happen light is
polarized so it can be polarized in the
sense that light consists of you can
think of it as a sort of oscillator
electric
field
oscillations and magnetic field
oscillations they're at 90 degrees to
each other and you can have it be the
case that
the um
the light is oriented so that
the um uh
the electric field is going one way or
the electric field is going the other
way and those two different
orientations can be treated differently
by a crystal so for example calcite is a
common kind of crystal that has this
phenomenon that um uh light polarized
one way
goes at a different speed in a calcite
crystal from light polarized the other
way and so that means that in fact you
get you end up getting two images often
in the calcite crystal because those
light going different speeds means that
the refractive index is different the
light is bent differently so that means
you put it closed like this to look
through a calcite pistol and you'll see
a double image of the thing underneath
it because the different polarizations
of light were bent at different angles
as it goes as they went through the
crystal
uh
comment here by parker quartz
no they notice
imperfections like streaks
that are kind of molecular analogues of
cellular automaton
i don't know specifically about that i i
have looked quite a bit at crystal
growth because it is a good example
of systems that grow according to simple
rules and i've looked particularly
dendritic crystal boats like snowflakes
with arms and so on um streaking i am
i'm familiar with the phenomenon but i
don't know
what a
good model for it interesting thing to
look at
all right
well lots of interesting questions today
um thank you all very much for that
and uh i should sign off here
and see you another time thanks for